this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me today
you read books you know it's Chris Joel
I've still not put it together in the
right order I'll try for the second
shelf everybody's favorite show is
running Gary run and get out of my
office I'm standing even from that gray
the mountain myself we'll see what I
have indeed eaten that
in front of me I have an article from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact to get right is a point and a
ding and the prize for particular good
answers which is and today we are
talking about the Stephens Island Wren
later person in the in the lady Navy
maybe maybe just for those who don't
have their British naval history there
the lady may sound like a car at a start
of a Formula One race just solid alright
dunk we've been I can't remember the
acronym I get to eat this with his role
Navy is that it really yeah women's
Royal Naval Yard it's the renren there
we go our quote well that's the nineteen
forties isn't it because there's no such
thing yes you're absolutely right it was
1993 when when it all got got unified if
this has nothing to do with the Stephens
Island run but the deep jog that stuff
wow that it's the bird that's gonna
claim is it from Stephens Island I mean
pretty it quite as easy as that next
time even you my master
is there a Wikipedia article about it I
know Gina struggled I teased Gina's
traveler know what my hand it to look
there's a common rent struggle deities
troglodyte II so I thought if it was
around it - probably troglodyte each so
Mattel seus
alright what we have here is a strong
life ornithologist when I say honest you
say ologist on it on it no first time
I've ever be news right though confused
I haven't been slow well I've indicated
for you are wrong
Eurasian run is fragra dices traveled
itis this is the Stephens Island Ren
Traverse yeah the ollie
does it go through French alleyways yes
they are lay well you have slotted into
in demand perfect when I ate if I still
was balanced oh it looks you or not you
actually had a bus court didn't you
before yeah yeah yeah
we're clean shaven and fight for the
Stephens Island retina gentlemen along
so far we've re-established it's a
burden Stevenson Desiree everywhere
Steve well it's last refuge with
Stephens Island was on the run for a
horrific crime is committed well this is
last stand
no no it has three all the friends
though and they drove around the back
and red van and I needed to help you
know make the sparrows and would miss
the TV what what sort of birds well they
wouldn't fly would basically acts like
an ostrich or okay oh yeah yeah that's
good ah yeah Gary unbelievably you know
I know solid Stephens RN is flightless
and I'm giving you a point as it learned
not to fly seemed to be on Stephens
Island it being an island I did it get
there on a raft I like the idea of
learning not to fly us up again how
could we have bollocks maybe he didn't
like you maybe we didn't like Heights
yeah but that's not forget images that's
proactive like is there a difference
though between actively forgetting and
unlearning
welcome to epistemology today today bird
don't fly you forget or did he learn it
because it's also known as Lyle's
Ren why would its last refuge we
Stephens Island is it extinct okay was
it delicious
damn it that much faster yes but not
done to the rod
yes it was apparently delicious there
are only ever been five species of
flightless songbirds found what's
happened to them if Albany for the
Stephens Island run in particular by
what was it eaten by pests that were
introduced by humans
yes right any particular pass rat bring
me another plate of them that I may
consume them for like about my makers
Larry over where the audience are better
going we have a Lodi six in the ruined
Westland of the island seeing the last
little red enter his lips he goes I
really should have saved these yes
of you in see nothing is not rats cat
yes cats is technically correct could we
be a bit more specific
Panthers well just thinking of just
being in like a hotel room in a lonely
kind of guest house and suddenly from
inside the cupboard hearing you saying a
single cat from one chip screw apology
right a lighthouse keepers cat named
Tibbles yeah allegedly a lighthouse
keepers cat named tables and for a while
that was the accepted wisdom what is
more likely more than one cat and a
larger number of feral cats had come to
overrun the island
how many living wrens were actually
spotted none there now I bet they're not
spotted at all they've got sort of
virtual striations or stripes go and
just hit me not that it's actually kind
of Reiger are we've ground plumage with
with edges of ground so I'll actually
give you give you the stripes sir how
often were they seen by humans seconds
after the end of the cat's mouth only I
went when I was writing a pile on the
doormat here that the cat first said I'm
friends with you by leaving dead bodies
outside and when I do it it's wrong
never they were so small they were
essentially invisible I mean I like it
well you got my make my bees bees birds
and the next part of the talk is where
it gets to are only twice the lighthouse
keeper called it almost nocturnal
running around the rocks like a mouse
yeah well you would between chest by a
friggin cat yes that was that was the
problem then the cat's a the lighthouse
keepers then the cats took over the
lighthouse and turned off the light many
ships were wrecked and even those crews
also were devout I mean you've got a
good ghost story there it's complete
bollocks if you've got a great job it
was once widespread throughout the area
whatever it is Stephen found in where we
gonna go see I mean technically i'ma
give you paradise which part of the
world this is 1870s New England No
Nova Scotia I mean you've been not sound
kinky yeah you you've said no that new
is correct
valence yes there we go other point
three historically it was Alton New
Zealand our land was settled its bones
can be found where kapu yes
it's not true you leave me alike a
primary school teacher with the six
students you're right
are there any other and as Ana classes
deposits left by laughing owl was that
an impression or a reaction if there's
all these darkly humid owl in a tree
watching all these verbs are these
reading losses you know what happened -
laughing else do they get eaten next yes
it is not laughing now are we I was
actually going to move on to other
extinct birds of music all is the mower
is that really [ __ ] big Eagle it's
the biggest one that ever lived
powerhouse starts in H ah car number New
Zealand
expecting three go
come on Topsy yeah the wonders of
technology that's a terrifying thought
the technology might be optimized to how
I think your rest of your screw talked
about introducing pests hello yes there
have been many many attempts attea West
particularly Australia and New Zealand
they're not pests their legitimate
countries we had words about this before
yes what can you tell me about the
rabbit proof fence
it wasn't rabbit proof hey because they
went under it yes it turns out that that
building fence was not a great way to
stop rabbits self you see getting in the
hat's of magician yes set apart flags of
all nations just loads of rubbish tied
together with the flags of all night
with the flag really I think it's
actually the rabbit of all nature
yeah what can you tell me about with
Cobra effect and the phrasing here is it
illustrates the causes of incorrect
stimulation in the economy a kid if it's
really sales of Viagra yes better they
interview the cobras but they're all
dead straight now flinging him like
Dublin glass how you doing here on B
where might this have been India yes
despite the break you out you are
absolutely right this was British
colonial India and they were concerned
about venomous snakes Cobras what did
they try to do to to solve the snake
problem did they bribed them yes set up
an elaborate passport service and they
couldn't move from place you know like
that thing was like oh we've got it he's
got it no to be fair he's got it was did
they
and then he's not was bribe did they
bribe the snake charmers people to catch
them and then they wouldn't get rid of
them all because if they got rid of them
all they wouldn't have an income so they
bred snakes to make sure they still had
a
I know that because that was a common
thing we were at top seventh year
sixteen seventeenth century you have
accounts of what they're doing parishes
and they have similar problems with
beavers you would bring the tails to
show that you had caught the pests so
you had yours had beetles that would get
rid of dogs things like that out of
churches but they were there were rumors
that they would be potentially breeding
animals to make sure they were still
getting paid for this little bit of
income so the similar thing yes they
offered a bounty for every dead Cobra
which worked then people started
breeding cobras so they scrapped the
bounty program what happened lots of
snakes I mean yes everyone releases the
cousin yeah I guess they were now
worthless so when they did it did they
use the product this needs your voice to
say that look at the coverage Shelley
release the Cobra sighs I'm in voluntary
picking my feel so that's clearly a
Disney Panthers Oh die is going to be
smoking the pipe Aspen yes ISIL quest as
a pastor in Seattle I can never go to
the city with different reasons though
to do with the shrub chucking the Cobra
so I'm just gonna go so it so to drag
this back drag it a long long ways the
Stephens Island rent
oh Jesus there were some fights over the
specimens between the cats obviously
because they were hungry the thing is
you're actually right because almost all
the specimens now extant were brought in
by cats always present as presents for
White House keep you're absolutely right
although they're not present there
they're sort of a mark of pity yeah yeah
if that kind of look that's how you do
it isn't it in the current thing showing
you it's that one this on the floor is
to show that angry it's true that's what
happened when you came to my house what
you saw the floor cuz you're right
he went stayed over in my hat ibid comes
before your stanky wasn't yeah you
stayed over in my out so that's how this
Amol off roads of gallery the cats on
the floor I have no memory of that
happened all if the only time she's ever
done it with another person in the house
normally we get it after a weekend away
or something a day or so let's just go
and like you know lay one on the con the
floor to say damn it you've been away
and this is how angry I am I'm going to
let you see this so for some reason she
took umbrage with you to that degree
this you get a massive dump in protest
and when I do it it's wrong on the other
hand I know exactly how my resignation
from the show's gonna go so yes what
happened to to most of the specimens
where they end up museums yes absolutely
right what happened to most of the cats
[Music]
shot sadly sir oh there was a did
someone ends up dead cat is found at the
end of the show yes it's not any luck
there was a recommendation sent out what
should lighthouse keepers not do have
cats to shoot in the first place yes it
was recommended a they not introduced
pests so then last the last question who
was Lyle who were they named after miles
ranch overseer layali was he the
lighthouse keeper yes so at the end of
the show conversations Chris you in this
water
are you want to stop Chloe and fired by
the villains Nightmare on Elm Street
it's a Teddy Krueger oh hey with that we
say thank you to Chris y'all is our
enemy
so we'll see what our job chocol dearest
god
you
you